- Super Bowl ads.
One final point, Gary.
- Buy them.
(audience laughs)
(electronic music)
You got your perspective.
(audience applauding)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
What's up guys, this is a fun conversation
we had the day after the
Super Bowl in New York City
with some great people from
Pepsi and Knotch and NBCU.
Super excited about the conversation.
Very macro-branding TV stuff
that I think is a different
look for some of you,
but there's some thematics in it
that can be unbelievably valuable.
So, some thoughtful
branding and marketing talk.
Hope you enjoy it.
- Despite any controversies,
advertisers are flocking to the Super Bowl
to get their brand messages across.
It's reported that CBS made $382 million
at five million per 30 second ad,
and it's not surprising because
three out of four people
say they look forward
to the Super Bowl ads,
and research shows that memorability
for brands in the Super Bowl
are 54% higher than
regular television norms.
So, it's really a great place
to put your ads regardless,
and we're gonna talk a
little bit about that today.
You know, people are
talking about them still,
they're watching them on YouTube,
and so, we want to talk
about what is the impact
that the Super Bowl has for ads today
using some of the Knotch
research measured these ads
and the positive impact
or negative impact that
people felt about them.
So, the first question
I'm gonna ask is to start,
maybe you guys can guess,
3,000 people in our
industry ranked the ads,
can anyone guess what
was the number one ad?
- Don't be shy, it's okay.
- Out of those 12 or all the ones that--
- Out of these, out of these.
- Out of these 11.
- Do you have a guess?
- So it was Amazon, Not
Everything Makes the Cut,
and next up was the Gillette,
We Believe The Best Men Can Be.
As a matter of fact, all the ads measured
mostly had positive impact and sentiment,
except for neutral was
Pepsi, More Than Okay,
Bumble, and Bon & Viv,
The Pitch, of that--
- That was actually the
only one that was negative.
- That was negative?
Oh I'm sorry.
That was the only one
that was negative.
- The last one
that we just saw, the mermaids.
I actually just realized,
this is like the third or
fourth time I've seen it
and I just got the Shark Tank thing.
I was like ugh.
I was so confused.
Anyways, sorry.
- Okay but why do you think,
and maybe Anda you can start
that the Amazon and
Gillette ranked so highly?
- Yeah well I think just at a high level
this is from a personal standpoint as well
as someone who watches a lot of the ads
and less of the football.
I thought this year was really interesting
because it felt like most of
the brands played it safe.
There was a lot of neutrality actually
in the sentiment that we captured
even though it was probably
skewing towards positive.
I think last year we
saw a bunch of back lash
against some of the advertising
that was put out there.
Some of the brands were trying
to take a bolder statement
using cultural
trends
and borrowing from the past
of different really great
people in American history.
And therefore sort of got in trouble
on social shortly after.
So I think this year we
saw a lot of the brands
playing it relatively safe.
Gillette I don't think was
actually on the Super Bowl
but as you all, I'm sure
almost everyone here
has heard about the ad before
even walking into this room.
And I think really what's going on there
is obviously tapping
into a massive revolution
that has happened over the last year.
I've heard very polarizing opinions
from different categories of people.
I think women have had
more positive reactions
than men on average.
I think it also depends
who Gillette was trying
to kind of aim towards.
Was it men of a particular type of belief,
men who kind of live in urban areas
and have already been touched
by a lot of the changes
that have come with the Me Too Movement?
Or was it a very different
category of people?
So I think a lot of these
questions actually pop up for me.
I'm kind of the token
data nerd on the panel
and I think when we talk
about the Super Bowl
what I've noticed is brands don't love
hearing about data and measurement.
Everyone wants to have
a very strong opinion
when it comes to whether it works or not.
And I think the bigger question for me
which I hope we can tap into tonight
is to figure out what brands
does it make sense for?
What type of campaigns
Is it a brand awareness?
Is it a reach goal?
And then how do you really
kind of follow up that
on all the other platforms
that matter as well?
Which all the digital platforms.
How do you make sure
that you're creating more
than just this one moment in time?
And I'll give you just a quick example
which I was recently approved to use.
I was having a conversation
with the CM of Denny's.
They did a Super Bowl ad a few years ago
and they were offering some type of offer.
They managed actually
to bring a ton of people into Denny's
as a follow-up to the Super Bowl.
So there was a very significant
impact that they saw.
And they were able to
deliver on the promise
that they made in the Super Bowl ad
but then every time the
same group of people
would go back to Denny's,
they would get a neutral
to negative experience
because they actually
haven't figured out by then
how to scale the rest of the company
to the traffic and the promise
that the Super Bowl ad made.
So I thought that was a
really interesting example
of this is not just a once in a lifetime
or once a year type of thing to do.
You actually have to be very thoughtful
about how you use it
and how it then integrates
not just with the rest of your marketing
but with the rest of your business?
- So that's an interesting point
because as I was reading some insights
that journalists were writing about
from the Super Bowl advertising,
one thing that came out,
and Gary I'm gonna talk
to you about this one
is that many marketers
are using social platforms
to extend the Super Bowl ad.
And a lot of advertisers
prelaunch the commercials
to build up.
One example that I thought
was really interesting
was that the avocado growers from Mexico,
they went to social to
actually make guacamole
like a Super Bowl item that you serve.
And they sold 58.4 million avocados
for the Super Bowl this year.
And that was before they even
advertised in the Super Bowl.
So I mean this is a huge
change than 10 years ago
and if you could talk a little bit about,
I mean I know you did a
lot of work with planters
and social impact before and after.
If you could talk a little bit about
how you think it's changed
and what marketers can do to use social
to really extend the life of
their Super Bowl investment?
- Thanks, thanks for having us.
So from my standpoint it's like
why wouldn't you use tools
that are available to you
to drive your business?
So social to me is a slang term
for the current state
of where people spend
their time on the internet
which is all about attention.
What's the purpose of these ads?
Awareness or attention is,
that's the best part about the Super Bowl.
You're gonna get consumption.
To me, it's why it's my
favorite piece of advertising
in the world in the US, excuse me.
It is going to get consumed,
whether on YouTube the week before,
whether during the game,
whether the next day,
this is going to get consumed.
So that's exciting.
And then to not use social,
as a matter of fact,
I actually think brands
should really consider
not showing it on YouTube.
For five years I was all
about showing it on YouTube
and now I'm wondering if for next year,
maybe they shouldn't
because some of the surprise elements
are being eliminated during the game
and I'm just kind of like feeling
like is this the tipping point
where you want to pull back?
But it all leads to the biggest punch line
which is these are businesses
that are trying to drive business.
And this is one of the
opportunities at their disposal.
But so is Twitter the week before
and so is pre-roll YouTube the day of.
And so I'm fascinated
by people's binary
points of view on things.
It's obviously a mix of a
lot of different things.
But this is a cultural event.
We're having a business event around it.
We don't do that for the
Grammy's or the Oscar's
or the NBA finals.
So to me, what do I think about it?
I think anybody who doesn't
have a robust strategy
to do creative and media amplification
on the platforms that
dominate our mobile devices
is in outer space in 2019.
- So you mentioned creative
and yet, in this room,
I'm sure so many people
created ads that they're so proud of
yet there's a lot of ads in the Super Bowl
like I'm not sure if
anyone saw the Chunky Milk
by Mint Mobile.
My family was so horrified and grossed out
and just thought
that was the worst
commercial they ever saw.
Yet people are talking about Mint Mobile.
So does creative really
matter for the Super Bowl?
- Creative is the variable
of success, the end.
So yes it does.
The bigger question becomes
does everybody talking about it
mean people are gonna go buy it?
The industry coming from the outside
of growing up in retail
and SMB and investing
and now coming to it,
talking about it or winning
these awards or the rankings,
to me somebody within all these companies
actually cares about the business.
And so I think yes, creative
is the variable of success.
Did it inspire
or make you think that
you want to consider
and then buy these products?
A lot of people know
that I have a big passion
for volume of content,
quantity which our industry
believes means not quality
which I think is silly.
But I, for the whole decade
that I've been in this industry,
continue to preach that the
creative is the variable.
So yes I do believe it.
I believe if you watch a commercial
and you think that product
sucks because of it, that's bad.
- Okay.
So speaking of great creative,
I loved the Bubly Buble commercial
and got such a chuckle out of it
and Stacy here is one of the
creators behind the commercial
from PepsiCo.
So Stacy, it's interesting
because more than half of the
presubmitted Super Bowl ads
had celebrities in them
including your Bubly Buble commercial
yet you used humor.
Do you think celebrity
is the greatest driver
of sentiment, humor?
Tell us what was behind
your thinking in that
and how those individual items,
celebrity, humor,
really make your decisions
and where you're going?
- Sure.
First of all,
also I think creative is the
utmost importance in this
and we know when we
look at mixed modeling,
just to build on that last point,
two-thirds of all ROI and sales
comes from creative effectiveness
more so than even the media.
So it's hugely important
that we feel like we have
excellent creative at all times.
And I think to answer your
question about the brand
and about Bubly,
the first thing is what
job are we trying to do
with the Super Bowl ad.
And so a Pepsi and a Bubly
are doing two very different things.
For Bubly, that brand has
been around less than a year,
has relatively low awareness
but is really catching
on and catching fire
and people are talking about it.
And we said this is the moment,
we're at an inflection point.
We want to drastically
increase our awareness.
But do so in a way that's
consistent with the brand
which is built on this idea of
fun and playful instigation.
So when we were looking at creative,
we didn't brief in has
to have a celebrity.
We didn't brief any of that.
We briefed what our objectives were,
what the brand is about
and then the creative that
best got the brand out
told people what it was
and did so in a way that
was worthy of Super Bowl
was finding a celebrity whose name
happened to be very closely
related to the brand name.
And so it was a little bit
of a happy coincidence.
I think celebrity always helps
in driving PR impressions, talk value.
But we would never have done it
at the expense of landing
the brand message.
- So as a follow-up question,
Bubly didn't have a lot of
advertising, like you said,
or awareness prior to the Super Bowl.
You went all in big with the Super Bowl.
Where do you go from here?
- We'll have a full year of support
this year on Bubly.
So we're using this as a launch platform.
We had a full campaign,
pre, during and post
around digital and social
and a lot of different channels.
In fact, during the Super Bowl,
we had teams going out
in a bunch of cities
and putting Sharpies on our product
so that consumers could find Buble
instead of Bubly the next day.
And so we had a lot of fun with it.
And going forward,
we're gonna continue to have a full year
of marketing and
advertising on this brand.
We don't want to have a boom splat
where people find out about
Bubly and then forget about it.
This is the beginning of a long journey.
- And what kind of sentiment
were you seeing in the social?
- Extremely positive, extremely positive.
It was 15 to one positive to negative
and it was called out in a lot of places
as one of the winners from
positive sentiment perspective.
- That's great.
So Anda, according to Twitter,
24 hours after the game
the words boring and Super Bowl
were tweeted over 70,000 times
and the words worst and Super Bowl
were tweeted together over 50,000 times.
So do you think that the circumstances
of the Super Bowl itself
affect the effectiveness
of the ads in the Super Bowl?
Does the research that you're looking at
show a difference there?
- Yeah, 100%.
I think it influences
the level of attention that people have
when the breaks actually come in.
I think the level of emotional intensity
is also just not there.
I think if you're in a mood
where you're rooting for someone
and you're very heated and
talking with your family about it
and then you see an ad that's great,
it just hits home in a different way.
And so yeah, I do think
that the fact that the game
as someone was telling me on my team
that it was the lowest score
in history for the Super Bowl,
yeah the fact that it
wasn't a very exciting game,
I definitely think made
the overall advertising
just not look as exciting.
But I also think that
the overall advertising
just wasn't as bold as it usually is.
And so from a creative standpoint,
actually one of the things
that I was wondering
is to what extent has the last two years
of all these massive revolutions
that deal with diversity,
to what extent has it made brands
just be fearful about what they can say?
And essentially turn,
I think it's a good thing
that a lot of brands turned
to comedy and kept it light.
Because at the end of the
day, it is a football game.
But what does that mean
from a creative standpoint?
How can you cater to everyone?
Does that mean that you're
basically not catering
to anyone in particular?
And what sort of campaigns
is that good for?
- So what kind of special
considerations then?
I mean and you can all answer this.
I mean at NBC Universal,
we had the Super Bowl
every three or four years
and we actually built an AI optimizer
to help advertisers look at the creative
and help them improve it.
So there are things,
we look at the creative itself,
do you use a celebrity, do
you use dogs or children?
Those tend to sell really well.
The messaging,
how long do you keep
your logo on the screen,
all these kinds of things.
And help marketers drive impact.
What kind of considerations
do you tell marketers to use?
You can speak,
all of you I think should
answer this question.
- You know it's interesting
how you set up the question
with dogs and children.
Nothing gets more engagement on social
than dogs and children
and nothing sells less
product for businesses
than dogs and children.
So I tell clients a lot when
we first start talking to them,
when they want to make engagement
or other metrics that have
nothing to do with their business
as the KPI for our existence.
I literally look them
dead in the face and go,
my ability to game that
and be the greatest you've ever seen
is so scary good
but you probably won't
see the business results.
- How do you know that dogs
and children don't sell?
- Well because one of the great things
about how Vayner looks at things
is because we have creative
and media under one roof
and the only KPI we trade on is selling
whether DTC on Amazon
or their own platform
or doing massive holdout clusters
in Walmart's or things of that nature,
what was unique about how
our business was built
was we weren't one
discipline or the other.
I didn't know anything about
the ad world when I started it.
And so because I was
building it for myself
with the hope of buying
businesses and running through it,
our religion from nine
years ago still to this day
has always been business results.
And so when we look at,
in the beginning of my career
when I would look at reports,
whether it was traditional reports
or things like data logics that came along
that helped Facebook justify,
when I was looking at internal MMMs
and all these things were doing one thing
but then the actual
business was doing another,
and then the cliche answers of like
because media and creative were split,
it was their fault or that fault,
it became a very interesting model.
As we've gotten deeper into the process,
the beauty of Amazon
and direct-to-consumer
or the sophistication that happened
as we built a big analytics
and media department
that allowed us to hold out
regions, stores, locations
with consistency over
three years, sales lifts--
- And so when we look at
testing Super Bowl ads,
we use Blink and Miller Brown
and some of the same tools
that we typically use
and we look at all the same metrics
and then we add viral potential
just for Super Bowl ads.
So still brand linkage and
engagement and enjoyment
are still the most important things
but then we also add this as extra metric
to make sure that it has talk value.
But we would never sacrifice
brand linkage or anything else
in favor of that if that makes sense.
- Anda, is there any research
or stats that you have
that marketers should consider
when they're making Super Bowl ads?
- Do you know, it's interesting.
I think one of my friend's
companies, Neural Insight,
was researching I think
10 of the ads in advance
and kind of helping with
the creative pretesting
and as it turns out
from both his work and ours,
what we see time and time again
is that what's right for one brand
is not right for another brand.
And so I agree with what
you're saying about dogs,
although I do remember that
the Budweiser puppy thing is,
I have a good feeling about Budweiser
and I've never bought it but--
- That's an issue.
- Yeah that is an issue.
I don't drink beer.
- That's the fucking
punch line of all of this.
- But if there was puppy
next to a bottle of red wine,
I might have more favorability towards it.
But anyways, what works for a brand
doesn't work for another brand.
And so I think it's not
about trying to find,
I think our industry,
in general, is obsessed
with benchmarks and trying
to find these golden nuggets
that are going to transform your brand.
And that's not the case.
I think maybe if anything,
from both a personal standpoint
and what we've seen from a
brand awareness perspective
is that the constant mention of a name,
especially when that name is not known
is really, really important.
Actually one of my
favorite ads from last year
was the Tide ad.
I don't know if you remember it
but basically it was
just the funniest thing.
You kept thinking it was this other ad
but then it was a Tide ad
and they kept repeating that to you
and I came out of that
and again, I guess I haven't
bought Tide but at least--
- That also matters.
And I think what really
is exciting for me,
and look, I'm a buyer of Super Bowl.
When NBC gets it again,
these were five million, make it 10
because I think they're really underpriced
and I mean that.
- Please don't.
- I mean it.
I think they're grossly
underpriced for the attention,
I really do.
When you look at the
delta between Super Bowl
and then the next 10 most expensive ads,
whether it's the AFC/NFC
championship game,
the NBA finals, the Grammy's, the Oscar's.
They're expensive
and yet nothing like this is gonna happen.
So I think they're very underpriced.
But I think the most important thing
that happened so far in this talk for me
is when you said I didn't buy it.
But maybe if that dog was
next to a glass of wine
it'd be more interesting.
There's something called Facebook
and Google and YouTube and Twitter
which actually has remarkable data
to understand that you
do have a propensity
to like red wine or dogs
or things of that nature
and we can put those ads in front of you.
I'm super fascinated
by the unbelievable capabilities
of some of the modern platforms
to do the thing that you just said
that is the most true thing
which is it has to resonate,
back to your point earlier.
What's really tough
about television for me,
I'm obsessed with the overall awareness
back to the names and
things of that nature.
My favorite ad in the last
10 years I've stumbled upon
was a Versace ad
where the entire ad is just
people saying the word Versace.
Like I'm a buyer of
certain things like that.
But after this and what it does,
I'm so obsessed with the fact
that we actually now do live in a world
where puppy, red wine gets
in front of you does exist
and yet there's a
disproportionate underestimation
of what that actually means.
- But I think what you're saying
also taps into the fact
that there's segmentation when it comes
to sending the right
message to the right person
and then maybe in the
context of the Super Bowl,
given the fact that you're reaching
so many people at the same time,
what you're really trying to do
is either launch a new product
or try to change your brand's perception.
But for anything else
that's more targeted,
for stuff like Tide that
everyone already knows about,
is it as effective?
Would you pay 10 million for that?
- Somebody said to me,
Gary but we have 99%
brand awareness already.
And I go and eight percent relevance.
The reality is consideration.
To your point,
and I think you're making the right point,
we use the word content so much
and we don't use the word context enough.
And I think a lot of where you're going
is exactly right.
And so for me,
I'm just fascinated that one,
and it's funny you brought
up the Denny's thing
'cause that actually happened
like seven or eight years ago.
- Yeah it was awhile ago
and they haven't done it since
and they won't again.
- Because their product sucks.
If you think about what they
weren't able to deliver on,
they actually got people in.
So I've been watching
it for a long time too
and I want to hear what--
- I think that's relative
if it sucks or not,
depends on the audience.
I think a lot of products that
were on the Super Bowl suck.
- No, no, the product sucked
because they were able to get
a massive influx of users,
CAC,
but they weren't able to
retain it, LTV, right?
- Yeah, so they basically
figured that out and said,
we can basically go back for scale
until we figure this out internally.
- Correct.
But what they did worked.
To me, what I loved about that ad
and have for the last seven to eight years
is it worked.
It was more utilitarian
which I loved about it
and which I think is a need
within this Super Bowl.
Their unique issue, to your point
was the product didn't allow them
to get the value in their LTV
because of the product.
A lot of things that happen in
advertising are funny to me.
We win and we lose
predicated on the actual thing.
There's a lot of people
that are part of successes
'cause the product was phenomenal
and the advertising was just fine.
The product was phenomenal.
So there's a lot to unpack there
but I do think context is something
that we need to talk more about
and utility to the Super Bowl
I think is an untapped opportunity.
- Let's talk about it.
So can you change people's opinions?
The NFL, they had their ad
for the 100 years of the NFL.
I'm not sure if you saw that one.
It had so many players.
It was ranked number one by USA Today
which is actually regular people
ranking the Super Bowl ads.
Do you think that they,
with all the controversy that they've had
that that ad has now changed the sentiment
of how people feel about the NFL?
- I think it helped.
And I think they have a
long way to climb back from
but what I liked about that ad
besides the fact that I feel
like it was a little cheating
'cause they didn't have to pay
for the hotel and the
air time and everything,
and it was two minutes long,
but it was just fun.
It was what people like about football.
It was fumbles and
interceptions and throwing balls
and people falling down and
all the talent that we all love
and that's what everyone's
craving from the NFL,
not all the other baggage that
has come with it this year.
And so I applaud them
'cause I think they got back
to what people want to see from them.
- It definitely didn't
change anybody's mind
whose disproportionately overly passionate
about the concussion issues the league has
or the flag issues.
No different than Gillette.
One of the things that's
so important about ads
when things are going on in real life
is understanding where
people sit on issues.
So like if you're a mother of a son
whose got five concussions
deep in high school
and is starting to deal with issues
because of the sport of football
that you're blaming for that,
that ad's doing nothing for you.
If you're somebody
completely in the middle
and kind of like whatever,
maybe it did move you a little bit.
And so I think that's
an important variable
in those kind of things.
- I think it's so hard to change
perception with one thing,
especially one thing that airs
during your biggest event.
I think you have to try harder.
And do it at scale and use
volume as well as context
throughout the entire
year to get that done.
- The other thing is
I think we talk a lot about things
and everybody here is a keyboard warrior
and a real champion out there
publicly on social media
but then our actions are different.
So there's a lot of people
that say a lot of things
and then act differently.
NFL ratings did quite nicely this year
because the games played out
differently on primetime.
I think there's a lot of,
the level of hypocrisy in
our society is staggering
and people are tough
guys and gals on Twitter
about products and services
and then they spend their
money in a different way.
- So speaking of products and services,
Verizon, they took a route
of acknowledging first responders
and then tying it back to the NFL.
Do you think that that made
a strong impact for brand
or did it get, were people confused?
How does this have to do
with my wireless service?
Stacy go ahead.
- I'll let you go first.
- Yeah I mean I think some of those,
I think Verizon and T-Mobile and auto,
I think a lot of those industries
are really hard to land
the what brand it's for.
I thought Verizon did a really good job
and I thought linking
it to the NFL players
and being contextually
relevant made a lot of sense.
I'm not sure anyone,
in a few months people are gonna remember
that it was Verizon.
I think they'll remember the ad
'cause it was a really
beautiful, powerful ad
but I think it's really,
to Gary's point,
unless you have cell
phones all over these ads,
I'm not sure it's landing
a product message.
If you remember it's Verizon,
you might think more positively about it
but first you have to
remember it's Verizon.
I don't know.
- So we work with almost
all the big telcos.
I think Verizon's the only
one we don't work with yet.
So I can't speak to the data itself
but what I will say
is that by and large,
almost all of the other big telcos
aren't making necessarily
this type of advertising.
They're a lot more focused on
the innovation, utility piece
and the educational piece.
For what it's worth as a consumer,
I've been exposed to a bunch
of their videos in the series
and I've actually remembered
that Verizon is the company
that helps first responders
pick up the call.
And for what it's worth
it's made my perception more positive.
I think there's a long way to go now
in terms of educating me
why it's a better option
but from a perception
standpoint, it's worked for me
and I love the ad.
And the thing I love the most about it
is that it actually created
a thread for me over time
as opposed to just this one thing.
I think if it had been just one thing,
I agree with you,
I probably would have forgotten about it.
- Want to say anything about it?
- I didn't love it.
- It didn't hit your heart strings?
- Nope.
- Why didn't you love it?
- I didn't remember it.
I watched it again,
it came at the end.
I just thought it was poorly executed.
I hate things that happen at the end,
like the URLs that people
are trying to send it to you.
ESPN established this 15 years ago,
put it at the bottom the whole time.
You're asking people,
I don't know, I just didn't love it
and I also think look,
I'm always thinking about
things like this of like
what normal human being is
going through the process
that we are right now?
None.
And so I'm trying to understand,
do we become caricatures of ourselves
'cause we're in the bubble
and are analyzing it at a
level that is just not real
or is this us synthesizing
what people are actually going through?
But for me I didn't love it
because I didn't remember it.
I didn't remember it when it showed here.
And even the way it was executed.
I don't love the unveil
at the end kind of thing
and it didn't pull at my heart strings,
not that I'm thrilled somebody's
got to be the phone service
for first responders.
I don't know, not for me.
- I think you hit on a
really important point
which is simplicity.
So I think when you have a
lot of exposure to a campaign
and you study it and you
watch it a few times,
it's different.
The vast majority
of the 100 million people
that are gonna see this
have two seconds,
they look at it, they might chuckle,
they might feel something in their heart
and then they're on to the next thing.
And so keeping it simple, I think,
can be really important.
- Yeah and the vast majority
is actually 99.99%,
right?
- Yeah, exactly, right.
- But speaking of pulling
at the heart strings,
it wasn't one of the ads we showed
but the Microsoft really
pulled at the heart strings
yet I'm not so sure that I was left
knowing what the product was.
I knew it had something
to do with video games.
Anyone want to comment on that?
- I just think high consideration products
are never gonna do that
well at the Super Bowl.
I think low consideration products
that need to get differentiated,
that need to get launched,
that need brand awareness,
are gonna be good
but any high consideration product
that has a longer sale cycle, very tough.
- So can I ask you a question on that?
- Yeah.
- So those kind of items on regular TVC,
outside of Super Bowl?
- No, I think, again, if you're trying
to talk about the awareness
or get the awareness, it might work.
I think from an educational standpoint,
30 seconds doesn't help with that.
I think you need a lot of content
and I think you need to
target it at the right people
at the right time.
- Yeah, that's why the awareness,
that's the thing I'm
trying to work through
which I appreciate.
I think that's exactly right.
Awareness, and then I'm
trying to understand the delta
of literally every other
commercial but the Super Bowl's
ability to actually get awareness
and actually be consumed,
not potential GRPs.
And so that's an interesting
concept of awareness
in a medium that,
it's scary for me to
think what this audience
let alone or anybody in America,
their behavior switches to
Amazon Prime, Hulu and Netflix
as just where you consume period
and then what's left
over the last five years of commercials,
what's actually being consumed
versus looking at your phone.
It starts getting to
scary territory for me
for the ability to build awareness.
- But look at GoDaddy.
I just have to say GoDaddy,
who knew about them before the Super Bowl?
Was there any GoDaddy in
this year's Super Bowl?
- Expensify tried
and I was pumped that Two fucking
Chainz was in the building
but I'm not sure if they pulled it off.
- I would just go back to
Microsoft for a second though
'cause I wonder if you're making that ad,
if your objective is to really get people
to understand what that product does
or if it was a brand perception
equity kind of driving thing
that is then supported by other media
that sells the actual product.
So it made a lot of people feel something
and Microsoft doesn't often
make people feel something
the way Apple does.
So I think that my guess
is it was more about
trying to change their equity
and change their perception a little bit,
not so much about trying
to explain the product.
- I don't know if this is just me
but I think if you're trying to do that
and trying to kind of aim
at your millennial hipster,
I don't know if the Super
Bowl's the best time to do that.
I almost feel like
if you are at the Super Bowl,
you're not gonna be perceived
as this super cool brand
that young people are going to embrace.
So if you're trying to sell a
product towards that audience,
I think it's tough.
And again, like Microsoft
has great brand awareness
I think when it comes to educating people
and getting them to perceive
you as a cool brand,
changing that perception,
I think you can turn to other places
for less money and more target.
That's just me.
- I wasn't sure if I was
getting the five minute sign
from the back?
She's not paying attention.
- Laura, do we have
more than five minutes?
- Are you giving the five minute sign?
I saw you hold up that--
(speaking in distance)
Okay, alright.
- Just waving.
- There's Q&A.
- Q&A will be coming soon.
So in your opinion,
if a brand is gonna choose
one thing to shell out
is it celebrity, licensing
an iconic piece of music
like Funky Town, CGI?
God what else is there
they could spend a lot of money on?
Two minutes long commercial.
What would you choose?
Stacy, what would be the
thing that you would invest?
- It depends.
No it does.
I mean again,
I think based on the
creative development process
and what your objectives are
and what your brand stands for,
a brand like Bubly is
always gonna lean on humor
and will more likely use a
piece of music or a celebrity
or might use animation.
But it depends on the creative idea.
I think you do need
something for Super Bowl
but I think that something needs to be
an excellent creative idea
and then the bells and
whistles that are around it
should add to that,
shouldn't cover up something that's just
not good to begin with.
So I wouldn't, I don't know,
next year it could be something different
than I would choose this year.
- Anda?
- Look, if there's a formula for success,
I think marketers would be billionaires
and we would be out of
business as a data company.
I think there's different things
that have worked for different brands.
At a high level,
the things that I've been
saying throughout the panel
is I would use it for brand awareness
and I would try to mention
the name a million times
to make sure that people
do stick with something,
even if it's a 30 second slot.
Take someone like Bumble.
I think if I were an innovative company,
I wouldn't necessarily turn
to the Super Bowl for this.
I think there's potentially
a negative brand equity
that you get amongst young people
if you turn to the Super
Bowl for awareness.
So that's just me.
- Two minutes.
- You would spend the
money on the two minutes.
- In the way you asked the question, yes.
- Okay.
- I just think it's grossly
underpriced attention
and then to everything
you're hearing up here
the variable is the creative
and the moment in time and the context.
I think that the price
is very, very underpriced
mainly because of the
reality of businesses.
I'm stunned by how much the
biggest brands in the world
are willing to spend on television
outside of the Super Bowl
and I'd prefer them just
buy Super Bowl at scale
and then take their dollars elsewhere
in some of the contextual other channels
that we've referenced.
So I think it's important
to not take it out of a silo
of what's actually happening out there.
And so what's actually happening out there
is there's brands
sitting there and saying,
ooh, Super Bowl's expensive.
Let me just spend 3.7 or 5.7
through the year on television
and I'm just deeply in belief
that they are just getting
absolutely no consumption of that.
And they're getting no consumption
in many digital places too,
programmatic banners and many other.
There's a stunning amount of money
being thrown directly in the trash
and I think Super Bowl is
not one of those places.
And I think current capability
of the social platforms
are not one of those places.
And then finding the creative
that's contextual for those platforms
is very, very important during this time
of the haves and have nots
which is why we're seeing
so many brands decline.
Because when you're wasting
95 cents on the dollar,
you're gonna get in trouble.
- Quick question,
do you actually believe that
every brand could benefit
from the Super Bowl?
Like lets say Salesforce or Knotch
could benefit from the Super Bowl?
- It's an interesting question.
I agree with where your macro statement is
that there's a time and place
but I will say this.
I do believe that every
brand can benefit from,
so the answer to your question
directly the way you asked it,
no, I don't think every brand can.
However, that gets in
contradiction with my belief
that it is so grossly underpriced
that if they were to understand
what to do with that time,
I think what we're trying to do
is too much entertainment and branding.
Back to utility,
I think that Salesforce,
if they ran their ad and said,
go to Salesforce.com right now
and fill this out if you're in B2B at all
or we're introducing this thing.
I do think the awareness
which I think we all understand has value
is actually there.
To me it's like,
it's crazy that it's actually there.
I don't know if I
mentioned this last year,
five or six years ago
I tried to buy a Super Bowl ad.
I tried to buy a Super Bowl ad
'cause I knew nothing
about buying television
and it was very expensive for a human,
it was basically about as much income
as I could've spent at
that point in my life.
And I was gonna run an ad
and it was gonna be a picture of my face,
I was gonna film it on my phone
and I was gonna be like, hey,
America, it's me, it's Gary,
follow me on Twitter,
Gary V-E-E and be out.
And I remember going through
the logic of that as a human
and saying this is gonna
be the best thing I ever do
because it's going to work.
I'm gonna amortize out
this attention and value
over the rest of my life.
I think that the attention
is so underpriced
in comparison to every
other option in marketing
that every business should
challenge itself deeply
to try to figure out,
how 'bout just using it
as a first party data collector?
And I'm passionate about that.
- While I love your
passion for the Super Bowl,
I would have to argue
so much about television
not being impactful
because we have so much research
that absolutely proves the opposite
including our biometrics
that show how we can drive
any KPI.
- Don't believe.
Not a buyer.
- Well, thank God.
Or we could have that
conversation another time.
- Or here?
I think when people spend
other people's money,
they spend it differently.
And so I think that I have empathy
but I'm always curious
what a lot of media buyers
and executives would do
if their actual children's health
depended on that media spend
versus what they do for a living.
- I think marketers
are trying to find ways
to be more engaging with consumers,
using the medium in a more
powerful and impactful way,
content and context,
putting yourself around brands
that really marry your brand
to a content brand.
Stacy, do you want to say something?
- Yeah, so we've done on Bubly,
outside of the Super Bowl,
the two big investments we've had
are on the television
side, are integrations,
media integrations.
So we have a big partnership
with the Ellen Show
and we've had an (mumbles)
and it's in show,
all of the content is in show.
- Love, love, love.
- Yeah 'cause to your point,
people are watching that--
- Love it, that's where
television started.
Ed Sullivan was brought to you
by a local town car Company.
People watch things,
the format of a commercial,
one of my favorite things that's happening
in marketing in the last five years
back to your point countering my point
is the way that television now with sports
is splitting the screen.
That's been a huge coup.
I believe that's a good move.
- Picture in picture is a huge thing.
Now even in entertainment.
And we're able to do actually
interactive picture in picture
and consumers are telling
us they like that.
We're seeing it in red carpet.
They want to see the behind
the scenes of what's going on
and you're right, we
all have to get better
at improving the commercial experience
and things like you're doing with Ellen
and integration opportunities
are huge and important.
And then there's things
like the Super Bowl
or the Academy Awards or the Grammy's
that are gonna drive huge awareness
and are around passion points
that consumers love
and whether it's like
fashion of the red carpet
around the Academy Awards
or music in the Grammy's
or the whole pomp and circumstance
around America and the Super Bowl.
- I think we should talk about things
like Instagram and Twitter's usage
during sports and the Grammy's
explodes during commercial time
as a real data point.
To your point,
listen, people have businesses
and they're driving their thing
and I have empathy for that
but this industry's really silly
when it talks about consumer
centric 'cause it's not.
It's business centric to the
KPI's of their businesses.
And I think a lot of that
creates vulnerabilities
that don't need to be there.
And I think if anything
things like Blockbuster
going out of business
and Netflix and Sears and Toys'R'Us,
there's so many indicators
that when you start doing things
that are in your best interest
in the short term financially
that are against what's
in the best interest
of the consumer,
that eventually becomes a losing formula.
And I do think a lot of
innovation on the TV side
would be a great idea sooner than later.
- Yeah, we're definitely seeing that.
We're testing new things at NBC Universal.
You have to do that to engage consumers.
So anyone want to say one final point
before I toss it to the audience for Q&A?
Super Bowl ads, one final point, Gary.
- Buy them.
- And spend $10 million on 30 seconds.
- I believe that.
- Make sure that it's the
right choice for your brand.
- Yeah that was gonna be
mine and creative matters.
Creative quality matters.
- Okay.
Yes, question?
- Yeah, well repeat it.
- [Male] I'm loud enough.
- We can throw the mic at you too.
- [Male] I guess the most
important thing that you're saying
is that you have to know
what you're doing the ad for,
what your goals are.
Because is the only goal to sell product
or is there a longer term goal
which as you were pointing out Gary
that there's an interplay between
for better or for worse with social media
that is gonna have to resonate
because people are on their cell phones
as much as they're on anything else?
- Well I think look,
these are businesses up here
and there's nothing wrong
with running a business
and trying to sell product.
I think the best way to sell a product
is they actually build a brand
and not be sales centric.
And so I what I think Super Bowl does
is gives you that potential
to do the holy grand.
The best sales people
are the ones that built a brand
and then let people come
to them in perpetuity.
So I do think the Super Bowl offers that.
So yes I think that's the goal
but like obviously short
and long term goals matter
and this is what's so amazing
on branding and marketing
over DR selling and
intent based Google ads.
You can actually build something
that gives you longevity.
- [Male] And in regard to the social media
and the interplay between
that and the social media?
Does anybody else have a comment
or any thought on that?
- I mean look, I actually am,
when I was saying that
you should accompany that
with other digital assets,
look, social media's great.
I think it creates a lot of noise.
I don't love social media from
a data collection standpoint,
no one does.
There's not a lot of room to
truly understand your audience
or to be able to harness that data
in a strategic way for your brand.
So I think it's great to think
about the higher level stuff
and then with the kind of
brand awareness campaigns.
But I think fundamentally
you need to figure out a way
to drive people back
to your own properties.
You have to figure out
how to have a direct
conversation with your audience.
And that's really the only way
you can start driving towards sales.
At least in our world,
in the B2B world.
- [Lee] Hi, my name's Lee Nabidor.
I'd like to spur this discussion.
Let's assume yes, Super Bowl, okay.
One of the things that I
thought was really interesting
and I know it's a word that's
thrown around is authenticity.
Forget the celebrity for a second.
Let's talk about actually entertainment
versus product explanation.
I thought Bud Light did
some interesting things.
One was up there
but the other ones that were up there
with the corn syrup and so forth
and trying to do it in an entertaining way
but actually making a
point about the product.
But two years ago I orchestrated
a campaign for Mini Cooper
called Define Their Goals
and it was basically a program
that had celebrities, was entertaining
but when we looked in the mirror and said
what is it that people are
saying about our product
and how do we defy that
with celebrities who
also define that label
and have a mini?
My question really is,
and I don't think we touched on it,
when you look at something
like Gillette, okay,
the criticism that I heard
and I could be debated either way
and I'd love to hear from
you guys on authenticity.
What was the problem that they had
by either having the conversation
or did they not have an authentic thing
beyond just putting the
conversation out there?
And I think it's really
interesting to look at
when you're gonna make a big statement,
it's easy to say we don't
have corn syrup and all that
but if Gillette is gonna say
we're the best a man could be
and we're gonna do this
and support women's issues,
and then they don't actually
support the women's issues
that becomes a problem.
And I just want to ask I guess the group
about brands making statements
that are in the social discussion
and how authentic do you have to be
to get into that kind of discussion?
- So I would say Proctor and Gamble
is actually putting their
money where their mouth is
and are leading the charge
with changing the way
that women are portrayed
in media and advertising,
with #seeher, right?
- [Male] Yeah see her.
- So I think it could've been, right,
that could've been a miss
because people don't know that
if you're not in our business.
And how do you then attach
so that consumers know
that you are doing good
and it is tough I think to link together
what you're doing
versus making a big, bold
statement that they made.
And I could see
that there could be a
disconnect for some people
when they watch that ad.
- [Lee] More pointed,
whether Gillette or the others,
just people are going
and they're going deeper.
They're going onto social,
they're doing research on the brand
and what's the barometer for
we're gonna make this statement
and here's our backup for it's real
versus we're gonna talk
in a social conversation
and just have the discussion.
But there's nothing deeper.
- I think you know the answer.
Nobody likes somebody
who's all talk and no action.
That's just something we don't appreciate.
Hypocrisy's not cool.
And so I think yes, it's a really bad idea
to try to look the part
and not back it up
because people are looking
for that vulnerability.
Our judgment levels on each
other and businesses today
are enormously high
and so yeah, that's
always been a bad idea.
That's no different than
your product not being great.
So that's a different version
of your product not being great.
If you're gonna make the statement,
you've got to back it up.
And America is an interesting place.
We don't often mind the crime.
We mind when the person's
trying to cover it up.
We don't like to be fooled.
And so yeah if a company comes out
and they're trying to make a big to do
but then their actions
don't speak to that,
but that's happening every day.
You look on the coasts,
the amount of people that
talk about the environment
but aren't willing to talk about
that their Prada bags or
their clothes and textiles
are driving some of the
biggest damage in our society,
we are one to two issue people.
And so like--
- [Lee] That's kind of what I'm asking.
How deep do you have to go?
- I think it's really tricky
because even if you do back
it up with authenticity
and that is not easy,
and then you are about that.
And so even if you do it all right,
is it the right thing
to be about that issue?
You have to decide that
as a for-profit business.
And I do think having
a purpose in the world
is something that every
brand needs to have.
But tying that purpose to
a very hot social issue,
I think each brand needs to decide
if that's worth the risk.
By the way, did everybody see
the Miller New York Times ad
today responding to Bud Light?
That was awesome.
- Is it ever a good idea
to put somebody down during that?
- I think Miller responded great to that.
- I think the amount of people
that saw Miller's response
versus Bud's move
is an enormous delta
and I think that's an
important thing for me.
- But they could've done that
ad without actually calling--
- I loved it.
I'll be on the record saying I love it.
I think businesses need to
do a little bit more of that.
I think it's a very poignant point.
It caught your attention
that they were willing to even go there.
And I think back to us being hypocrites,
we don't like attack ads in politicians
yet it's very clear that it works
and so I think what I appreciated
was it was an attack
in a very, kind of softer way.
I thought it was clever
and I think there's more upside.
I don't know how big the
issue is for the end consumer.
I'm just not educated enough on that.
But it definitely got the point across.
And back to why I believe
in the Super Bowl,
man do I think very few people
saw the print ad in the Times
today at scale in comparison.
- Yeah I think that's true.
It's funny your point,
there was a lot of discussion,
positive and negative,
more positive but some negative
about the Pepsi commercial
had the word coke in it
and like oh my God.
- I love that you did it.
- Pepsi has challenged your brand.
That's what Pepsi does and that is a truth
that when you go and you
order a coke at a restaurant
they say, is Pepsi okay?
That is something that
is true in the world
and we've built off of that.
That said something about our brand.
But not everybody is
comfortable with that.
- And I think that's where we get too B2B.
I don't know if the head
honchos at Pepsi heard
but most of us know Coke and
Pepsi have some similarities.
We're just so not consumer centric.
- You have a question.
- Yes.
- I'm glad you did that.
- [Female] Super Bowl surrounds
a halo effect strategy or campaign.
So recently when I was watching
all of these ads on Monday,
a GMC ad popped up
on whatever website I was
watching these articles
and the title card came in
saying the Rams already lost,
went into selling GMC ad.
So super fast, super relevant.
They were prepared for it.
Had maybe two weeks notice
as to who was gonna do it.
I don't feel I'm ever pitched as a client.
What should my surround sound
of an event that could affect me be.
And so is that a more cost effective way
to leverage the Super Bowl
if I can't do a five to 10
million dollar 30 second spot?
- I mean if you can't do the spot,
you've got to do what you can do about it.
I think one of the reasons a lot of times
there aren't good holistic,
I used to always wonder
when I first got in,
why aren't people a little
more 360 with their campaigns?
And that was because I didn't understand
the dynamics of the
creative agency landscape.
I didn't know that creative agencies
thought everything besides TVC
was bullshit and garbage
and not of respect
and didn't mean anything
and after thoughts.
And so once I learned that,
then I understood.
I'm like oh okay
they just completely disrespected,
put no energy to it.
Plus then media's the
separate thing to begin with.
And the KPIs and we're not
gonna buy that inventory
'cause it doesn't achieve the low cost CPM
that we have to hit to get bonused.
And so real life takes over.
But that's a good idea.
And that's the punch line.
- There's a question
in the back I think.
- The right things aren't being done
because of the vested interest of partners
within the reality of this business world.
- So sorry as a follow-up,
is the solution then for brands like GPMC
to in-house more of their work?
- That sounds like a great idea.
I'm in disproportionate belief
that every brand in the world
should do all their marketing in-house
if they're capable to.
Being dead fucking serious.
The problem is--
- I was really hoping I'd
catch you with that one.
- I will never, ever put my
financial vested interest
in front of being historically correct
'cause that's where I
think people struggle
and make big mistakes.
The reality is if you're capable,
the problem for brands
when you play it out
is when the economy gets soft
and Wall Street doesn't
like all that overhead,
it helps to have,
so there's all these real things
but yes, I think anything
you can do better
for a better price with
better intent is a good idea.
- Question in the back.
Two more questions.
- [Male] Hi, quick question.
With digital marketing right--
- Can you hold your mic closer?
- [Male] Sorry, can you hear me?
In digital marketing, we
see a lot of personalized,
hypo targeted assets,
right, hitting consumers.
So my question is what's
going to happen to this,
to advertising in general
for the Super Bowl
when a streaming service
such as Netflix or Amazon
gets on the rights?
Because yes, we have CBS,
we have NBC Universal,
getting the Super Bowl
and they're investing
into streaming services.
But what happens when the
non-traditional streaming service
such as Netflix, Amazon,
gets their hands on the Super Bowl
in terms of how will that affect metrics?
How will that affect media buys?
How will that affect content in general?
Are we gonna see personalized content
or are we gonna see these
wide net advertising baits?
- So Gary said it before
in terms of we have to look
where the consumer is going
and we all need to work
together as an industry
to really change the ecosystem
of how advertising works
in the places that it's available.
And you also said you go back
to the day to day realities
of like I need to make
my OCF and hit my DNLs
and the reality set in
but the consumers aren't gonna stop moving
the way that they're moving.
And so look, there were pictures of Bezos
with the head of the NFL
and that's something that could be scary.
But can they really continue
to be non-profitable
and make money just on subscriptions?
Because a one way revenue stream
has proven that it will fail
and that you need dual revenue stream
with the price of content.
And you see someone like Facebook
who's unwilling to get
into the content game
because their margins
would go through the floor.
So it's really us working together
I think as an industry
to give consumers advertising.
Because three out of four
people who watch the Super Bowl
said that they were
looking forward to seeing the commercials.
It is part of the pop culture conversation
and they want creative
and they also want to be
informed about new brands.
So I really think it's working together
to make it better.
- My take on that is three
out of four sounds right
and low intuitively
but what about every other commercial
that exists in the world?
What's the polling on that?
And when Amazon gets the NFL rights,
it's gonna come down to how
they want to monetize it.
To your point,
how long will Wall Street
allow them to invest
and when does the bloom come off the rose
and that becomes the question.
But once you have that much
first party data and behavior,
nobody here,
I ask everybody here to ask themselves
how much they're willing
to pay for Amazon Prime
versus what they're paying now.
- Well Hulu, when they offered
the 99 cents for ad load,
most of the subscribers took the ad load.
So they couldn't--
- 'Cause Hulu's
one dimensional.
Hulu's one dimensional.
One more time,
how much is everybody willing
to pay for Amazon Prime
which delivers
all your products?
- I actually think
Amazon Prime is not as good as Hulu
and I think consumers in general--
- I'm talking about actual Amazon Prime.
The shit that everybody here has
to buy everything they buy.
- So whatever they charge is the answer.
- What we're having is we're
having silo conversations.
And when Amazon has last mile
and you can order toothpaste
and get it in 24 seconds in your door,
I think we're having a naive conversation
and when the entire, guys,
if the terrorists
attacked Amazon's
structure for the internet,
the whole internet would collapse.
Everybody is on the infrastructure.
So there is a lot of leverage
points that Amazon has
that we have to factor into this
because they have leverage.
Everybody here would
pay a lot more for Prime
'cause the value of free delivery
across all the products
and services they buy
is enormous
and that's just real life.
And it would be interesting to see,
and I don't know,
how much more are we willing
to pay for that core service
that is so important?
They layer on top of it.
I mean they have a lot of leverage.
- I think to your question,
it just means that we're all in this room
gonna have to get a
lot smarter and better.
And it doesn't mean that
we're gonna stop advertising
and brand building
but we're gonna have to
do it in a different way
and if the Super Bowl's
no longer the appetizing cultural event,
we'll find another way to do it.
- And we did it.
Super Bowl one wasn't even sold out.
The ads on Joe Lewis's fight on the radio
were a fortune in the '40s.
This is not that long ago.
We're always gonna move
to where the attention is.
The question becomes the ad formats.
The reason I love the Ellen integration
is that's good.
You're consuming that.
I think brands should be spending way more
integrating into the actual content
and how networks decide to do that
and things of that nature.
Amazon might come out
and not have commercials or who knows?
But what Amazon has is something
that nobody else has.
When they have the NFL rights
and you're watching your game
and a player scores a
touchdown and you're excited
and the friction of you being able to know
that because something just
happened during their game
that if you just say, Alexa,
order me a Sam Donald jersey,
it's discounted 'cause they're playing.
They're eliminating friction.
They're gonna make revenue
in a way other people haven't.
- [Male] You'll replay it on Twitch.
- Yeah but do you know what I mean?
They're eliminating friction.
You're watching a football game,
something good happens,
you're a diehard fan
and you're aware now through
marketing and branding
that you can just buy that
product through voice.
What we do all the time
is we make binary decisions
without understanding the other variables
that this infrastructure is creating.
That's gonna make them highly profitable.
They're content's valuable to them.
They sell shit.
NBC and ESPN don't.
- I think it's really
important to also remember
that a few years ago we
were talking about Facebook
exactly the same way.
I think there's gonna be
a lot of ethical issues
that come into play
that I think we should consider.
This idea that Amazon's
taking over the world
and they're gonna move their servers
and the Alexa's gonna fully integrate
and in a really creepy way
completely change our lives,
I think potentially
might have some checks
and balances in place.
- Sure the government gets involved
when somebody wins too much.
- Yeah but I think it's
even more than that.
I do wonder what the evolution
of Facebook is going to be
in a world where the consumer
is becoming a lot more vigilant
about what's happening with their data.
- Well if you look at
Instagram's behavior,
the answer is we go where we value things.
- It's a very different thing,
Instagram versus Facebook
and the brand awareness
around the issues of Facebook
for some reason don't
relate to Instagram for now.
I think they might.
- Because hypocrisy is cute.
- But we want one last
question in the back, right?
- [Female] Hi.
So I guess it's two questions.
If you were to see a red wine company ad,
would you have had a better
Super Bowl ad experience
and how would you have felt
about whatever that brand
was that showed that to you?
Because I feel like that's a valid one
to the original technology
but I'm wondering when
it's gonna come too late
because I think we're ready for it.
- Well I'm just gonna really
quickly say something.
I think there is an
element of me seeing that
and feeling like I discovered it
and there's something
really special about it
versus feeling like someone's read my mind
and has put that into my plate
in a way that feels really
creepy and intrusive.
I am one of the two to
five percent of people
who actually care about how
their data is being used
'cause I just know too much about it.
But I would say half
the people don't care.
I think that might change with time
and regardless it doesn't matter
because if five percent
of the people care enough
they're going to change the
way everything else works.
- Also consumers are moving
the way that they view traditional
linear television content
in a digital format
whether it's a Roku or you name your app.
And so those products are data enabled
and you're gonna see a huge shift
of being able to do
addressable linear television
like you've never been able to do before.
The technology is now catching
up with consumer behavior.
So I think it's a really
exciting times for all of us
but again, we have to protect the consumer
and give them their privacy
and be responsible with what we do.
And I would like to add
that Jeff Bezos did say
that television advertising
was one of the most powerful vehicles
and he wasn't a fan and changed
his mind in the last year
because he started to invest heavily
and see how it was driving sales
in usage of Amazon Prime.
- I think using fear as a
sales tactic is interesting.
And I think that is an important,
seriously, I think it's
a really important,
I think it's interesting.
First of all, everybody just has opinions
and then things play out
and I value massively
people that have different
points of view on things, massively.
I think that there's
ideologies around human beings
that historically humans
haven't delivered on.
And so that's what I'm trading on
but this may be the singular
issue and that's fine
and I think that's great.
- Well I think that wraps up our show.
Thank you Knotch for having us today.
(audience applause)
- Hey guys.
Thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me
and I could really use your support.